hit there's an example of somebody who's
a charismatic leader
that seems to have a really
disproportionate amount of influence
on the tide of history
so
you know if you look at stalin you could
imagine that
many other
people could have stepped into that role
and uh the same goes for many other the
other presidents through
or even mao
it seems that there's a singular nature
to hitler that you could play the
counterfactual
that if there was no hitler you may have
not had world war ii
he
better than many
leaders in history was able to channel
the resentment of the populace
into a very aggressive expansion of the
military and
i would say
skillful deceit of the entire world
in terms of his plans and was able to
effectively start the war
so
is it is it possible that um
i mean could hitler have been stopped
could we have avoided
if he just got into art school right
uh or again do you feel like there's a
current of events that was unstoppable i
mean part of what you're talking about
is uh is hitler the individual as a sort
of charismatic leader who's able to
mobilize
you know the the nation um and part of
it is hitler-ism right um his own sort
of individual
ability to play for example play off his
subordinates against one another to set
up a system and you know of that of that
nature that that in some ways escalates
violence including um you know the
violence that leads to the holocaust
um and some of it is also hitlerism um
as a as a leader cult and we see this in
many other sort of
you know things where where a political
movement surrounds one particular
individual who may or may not be
replaceable
um so so yes um the world war ii we got
um would have been completely different
if a different sort of
faction had risen to power in germany
but
but europe you know depression era
europe was so unstable
and democracies collapsed throughout
western europe over the course of the
1930s
you know whether they had charismatic uh
totalitarian leaders or not
have you actually read
one book i just recently
finished i'd love to get your opinion
from a historian perspective there's a
book called blitzed drugs in the third
reich by norman ohler
it makes the case
that drugs played a very large uh
meth essentially played a very large
role
in world war ii
there's a lot of criticism of this book
saying that it's it's uh kind of to what
you're saying
it takes this one little variable it
makes it like this explains everything
so everything about hitler everything
about the
blitzkrieg everything about the military
the the way the strategy the decisions
could be explained through drugs or at
least implies that kind of thing
and the interesting thing about this
book because hitler and nazi germany is
one of the most sort of written about
periods of human history
and this was not drugs were almost
entirely not written about
in in this context so here come along
this
semi historian because i don't think
he's even a historian he's a
a lot of his work is fiction
hopefully i'm saying that correctly so
he tells a really
that's one of the criticisms he tells a
very compelling story that drugs were at
the center
of um
of this period and also of the man of
hitler
what are your
sort of feelings and thoughts about
um
if you've gotten a chance to read this
book but i'm sure there's books like it
that tell an interesting perspective
singular perspective on a war
yeah i mean i i have read it and i i
also had this sort of eye-opening
experience that a lot of
uh historians did and they're like why
didn't why didn't we think about that
right um and you know i think uh whether
he's you know the the the author older
is um you know sort of not a trained
academic historian but the joy of
history is like you don't have to be one
to write good history and i don't think
anyone
uh you know sort of criticizes him for
for that
i like
the book as a as a window into the third
reich you know of course drugs don't
explain all of it
but it helps us see
um you know uh it see helps us see the
people who supported hitler
the ways in which
um you know
it was that
mind altering and performance altering
drugs were used to kind of keep soldiers
on the battlefield and the ways in which
um
you know i think that
we take we don't fully understand the
extent to which the third reich is held
together with like duct tape from um you
know from a pretty early phase by like
1940 or 41 even you know it's all smoke
and mirrors and
i think that wartime propaganda both
germans trying to say you know we're
winning everything and america trying to
mobilize uh and the other allies you
know to mobilize against germany
described a more formidable enemy than
it really was by 1941 and 42.
yeah i mean i could see both cases uh
one is that duct tape doesn't make the
man
but also as an engineer i'm a huge fan
of duct tape
yeah because it does seem to solve a lot
of problems and
i do worry that
this perspective
that the book presents about drugs is
somehow to the mind really compelling
because it's almost like the mind or at
least my mind searches for an answer how
could this have happened
and it's nice to have a clean
explanation and drugs is one popular one
when people talk about steroids in
sports
the moment you introduce the topic of
steroids
somehow the mind wants to explain all
success in the context was because this
person was on steroids lance armstrong
well
it's it like it's a very sticky idea
certain ideas certain explanations are
very sticky and i think that's really
dangerous because then you lose the full
context and also in the case of drugs
it removes the responsibility from the
person
both for the military genius
and the evil
and i think
it's a very dangerous thing to do
because something about the mind maybe
it's just mine it's sticky to this well
drugs explain it if the drugs didn't
happen
uh then it would be very different yeah
it worries me
how compelling it is of an explanation
you know yeah so that's why it's maybe
better to think of it as a a window into
the third round yes than an explanation
of it but it's also a nice exploration
of hitler the man
for some reason discussing his habits
especially later in the war
um his practices with drugs
gives you a window into the person it
reminds you that
as a human this is a human being
like a human being that gets
emotional in the morning gets
thoughtful in the morning hopeful
sad
depressed angry
like a story of emotions of the human
being is that the somehow we construct
um
which is a pretty dangerous thing to do
or construct an evil monster out of
hitler when in reality he's a human
being like all of us i think the lesson
there is the soldier instant lesson
which is
all of us
to some degree are capable of evil
or maybe if you want to
make it less powerful a statement
many of our leaders are capable of evil
that this hitler is not truly singular
in history
that uh yeah when the the resentment of
the populace matches the right
charismatic leader
it's it's easy to make the kind of not
easy but it it's possible to frequently
make the kind of uh
initiation of military conflict that
happened in world war
world war two
you